First up-- Why, robot.
Why, robot.
Hong Kong designer Ricky Ma
spent nearly two years
and $50,000 to create a robot
Scarlett Johansson.
-Oh!
-Oh! Robo ScarJo. -(laughter)
He carefully crafted it to have
the same physical appearance
as one of his favorite
Hollywood actress,
but unlike the real
this one does not know how
to file a restraining order yet.
(laughter, groaning)
Let's see Robo ScarJo in action.
I think robotics is
a new manufacturing.
(laughter)
Ma insists he won't use it
for anything tawdry.
Uh, which I guess is why
he designed it
to look like it's trying
to chew a dick off there.
(laughter)
(Hardwick imitates
robotic chatter)
(laughter)
Comedians, what do you think
this toothy robot
is trying to say here?
Maria.
Oh, sorry. I... (laughing)
Uh, uh...
(robotically): I want to chew
through your toaster cord
and watch your house burn.
HARDWICK: Yeah. Points.
That's gonna be her revenge
when she becomes self-aware.
Uh, Chelsey.
(in robotic voice):
I only make 75%
of what Robert Downey Jr. makes.
-(laughter, cheers and applause)
-HARDWICK: Points.
Randall.
(in robotic voice): Thank you,
Ricky Ma, for proving once again
Asians can do everything!
(cheers and applause)
-HARDWICK: They can.
-That's right. That's right.
Asians can make everything
(bleep)able.
(laughter, cheers and applause)
That's if you...
-That, too.
-That as well, that as well.
I only hope
the real Scarlett Johansson
doesn't become self-aware.